what did Barack Hussein Obama know and
when did he know it tonight we will
unravel the biggest abuse of power
scandal in American history and it is
more clear than ever before Barack knew
a lot how much we're going to dig deep
tonight also how involved was the former
president in deep state spying Russian
disinformation prosecutorial misconduct
unmasking weaponizing intelligence all
roads now lead right into his Oval
Office and breaking just moments ago
Acting DNI director Rick Grinnell is now
seeking to declassify any Obama
officials involved in the illegal
unmasking of general Flynn we will
explain this is a huge development also
Chuck Todd he got caught red-handed
manufacturing fake news shocker
humpty-dumpty fake news CNN is having a
boo-boo-boo-boo meltdown and the
Communist Party of China is trying to
steal our
kovin 19 vaccine research and a 300
percent jump inside walk homeless camps
in San Francisco is now causing a
massive outbreak
Nancy maybe you could bring some ice
cream or build a homeless shelter with
all your rich friends and your
multi-million dollar mansions and your
date in your gated community but we
begin tonight with our top story and
that is President Trump is calling it
Obama gate now Flint attorney Sidney
Powell is accusing the former president
of participating in a plot to frame
general Flynn and tonight huge news
Acting DNI director Rick Rennell is now
vowing to declassify the names of any
Obama official involved in the unmasking
of lieutenant general Flynn during his
foreign surveillance this is a huge
development now keep in mind the Obama
administration has long been accused of
improperly unmasking Flynn and others in
order to gain a backdoor to spy first on
the Trump campaign and his transition
team and then later his presidency deep
into his presidency as AG Barr has said
now this comes as newly released
interview transcripts from the Intel
committee that the congenital liar ship
was hiding show that Obama had an
unusual interest in the case against
Lieutenant General Flynn
now by January 4th remember 2017 is only
a mere 16 days before the president is
inaugurated the FBI's Russia collusion
investigation they found zero derogatory
material on lieutenant general Flynn his
case was all but closed until FBI
leadership in a panic demanded that they
reopen it and on the very next day
January 5th 2017 then President Obama
held a meeting with all of his top Intel
and security officials that would be
clapper Brennan Comey Rice Yates Biden
and others and after the meeting in the
Oval Office he then pulled both FBI
director James Comey and the Deputy
Attorney General Sally Yates aside for
the purpose of discussing Flynn now we
know from the testimony released late
late last week that Sally Yates
testified she was shocked to learn that
Obama had complete intimate knowledge of
Flynn's wiretap phone calls I'd say he
illegally probably on January 20th 2017
in the final hours of the Obama
administration
remember national security adviser Susan
Rice remember she went back she sent
herself a very unusual email and what is
a blatant cya maneuver she referenced
the president's January 5th meeting in
the Oval Office is on January 20th 15
days later and said that Obama said he
wanted all the investigations to be done
by the book said of 15 days ago why are
you writing this on Trump's inauguration
day why is Susan Rice memorializing a
meeting about Flynn in the Oval Office
do everything by the book Obama said can
it be any more obvious that the person
that lied on five Sunday shows about
Benghazi was scared to death that
Obama's plotting and scheming would soon
be exposed now in the days and weeks to
come commis FBI took unusual aggressive
and frankly unethical measures to
persecute general Flynn 33 year vet
knowing he was an innocent man
Comey McCabe struck coal ambushed
general Flynn at the White House on
day four of the new administration by
the way he called over to the deputy FBI
director McCabe and McCabe he advised
general Flynn that he did not need a
lawyer present he knew better they
significantly altered his original 302
we now as of late last week have that
evidence and then they turn the screws
on general Flynn they threatened him
with years behind bars they threatened
to lock up his son legal bills had
already forced this guy at one point to
go bankrupt he lost his family home all
over a simple process crime that they
concluded never took place and yet by
the way former President Obama is still
out for blood now the interesting thing
is is both Susan Rice and Samantha power
said oh yeah they were speaking with
their counterparts before they entered
the Obama White House the very thing
they were complaining general Flynn did
now an audio obtained by Yahoo News well
very sanctimonious self-righteous angry
Barack Obama is downright apoplectic
that Flynn won't likely be spending
years behind bars as a convicted felon
will explain his hypocrisy and double
standard in a second but first listen to
this the fact that there is no precedent
that anybody can find for someone who's
been charged with perjury just getting
off scot-free
that's the kind of stuff where you you
begin to get worried that basic not just
institutional norms but our basic
understanding of rule of law is is is is
it risk someone charged with perjury
gets off scot-free and and and wrongs
and uh oh yeah and and break the rules
okay despite what you just heard
Barack perhaps you forgot there's an
actual precedent from you one of your
favorite military advisors retired
general james Cartwright
well he's convicted of lying to the FBI
but guess what in 2017 Barack Obama the
hypocrite he issued a full pardon for
his favorite general Oh the rule of laws
in jeopardy in other words general
caught right got off scot-free and he
set the precedent Obama did of course
the Flint case was never about a simple
process crime instead it was part of
what was a larger plot to destroy the
incoming president look at the timeline
August 15 2016 Peter struck he compared
that to an insurance policy in the
unlikely event that Donald Trump wins
the election September 2nd 2016 his
lover Lisa Paige texting Peter struck
president Obama quote wants to know
everything that we are doing so that
clearly states Obama not only approved
of the persecution but he now seems to
be orchestrating it and now they're
trying to cover their tracks so again
the question tonight
Barack what did you know and when did
you know it Joe what did you know and
when did you know it because at the time
everything the deep state was doing was
corrupt to the core multiple Trump
campaign associates and officials were
being wiretap spied on
confidential human sources they lied to
obtain FISA warrants they took away
Carter pages let's see
civil liberties constitutional rights he
was the subject of for fraudulent paese
applications one year of his life that
relied on what Hillary's dirty Russian
disinformation dossier which apparently
we now know from Podesta's testimony
that they knew was from Russia
now commis FBI knew the material was
unverifiable garbage and it was bought
and paid for by the Clinton campaign
that will warn repeatedly before the
first FISA application don't trust
Steele Hillary paid for it and it's
unverified and according to newly
released transcripts from Podesta even
Hillary Clinton knew full well her
campaign was paying someone to dig up
Russian dirt on Donald Trump but let not
your hearts be troubled answers now seem
to be forthcoming thanks to the Attorney
General
thanks to prosecutor a bar a durham
attorney general bar and
station now are moving forward full
throttle and by the way being
coordinated with several other US
attorneys on this case and unlike
previous Inspector General
investigations this according to the
Attorney General bar is not about a new
report no this is a criminal
investigation and prosecution's
hopefully will be in the works was
unlike these inspector general they can
convene a grand jury they can indict
people and they can prosecute them and
tonight many current and former
officials they have reason to be worried
my source is telling me tonight that
some of them have now lawyer DUP with
the biggest names and most expensive
lawyers of Washington DC perhaps they
know what's coming and maybe that's why
nearly two thousand former DOJ employees
signed a letter blasting AG bar for
dropping charges against Flynn hmm
timing is suspicious don't you think
let's see deep State DC ëletís that are
loyal to Obama and Biden and call me the
message has gone out protect your own
protect the deep state
it sounds like Obama might have been
sending out warnings you guys need to go
back to work either way the propaganda
arm of the Democratic Party the media
mob they're also lashing out at the
Attorney General this is now part of a
systemic attempt to destroy Attorney
General bar for trying to get to the
truth and expose corruption and abuse of
power and of course they were hurting
president Trump and they were trying to
upend a duly elected president after
they failed at preventing him from
getting reelected by protecting his
opposition candidate and one instance
for example over the weekend NBC News
caught red-handed deceptively editing a
clip featuring the Attorney General
let's watch the Edit when history looks
back on this decision how do you think
it will be written well history is
written by the winners so it's largely
depends on who's writing the history
I was struck PEGI by the cynicism of the
answer it's a correct answer but he's
the Attorney General he didn't make the
case that he was upholding the rule of
law actually wrong again Chucky because
you might want to check the tape before
you go on one of your anti-trump you
know typical benders because these were
bars full remarks until you and your
network selectively edited it to sound
like it look like something that it was
not let's take a look when history looks
back on this decision how do you think
it will be written well history is
written by the winners so it's largely
depends on who's writing the history but
I think a fair history would say it was
it was a good decision because it it
upheld the rule of law it helped it
upheld the standards of the Department
of Justice held the stand at a
Department of Justice whoopsie-daisy
that's called context texture and NBC
News had to ultimately apologize for
their deceptive editing and bias but
will they ever apologize for Chucky's
abusively biased corrupt anti-trump
coverage masquerading as news Chuck your
note Tim Russert I won't hold my breath
you're just a few examples do you think
there's already do you think there is
blood on the president's hands
considering the slow response show me a
person who believes in Noah's Ark and I
will show you a trump voter it look this
gets at something Dean that that my
executive producer likes to say say
voters want to be lied to
Ukraine meddled in the American election
in 2016 I do and I think there's
considerable evidence you do you do why
a Fox News conspiracy propaganda stuff
is popping up on here I has no idea
exactly that President Trump is upset
and why his supporters are upset the
news media please
that's not even the most pathetic
coverage from the weekend which is
pretty much every second minute hour of
every day from every liberal news outlet
which is the majority of them this one
comes from professional Hannity and Fox
News stalker Goodall humpty-dumpty
Humpty was just seething with rage that
this network this show among others
covered the biggest abuse of power
scandal in American history
you know that would be the story that
Humpty and his fake News CNN Network
ignored as they push forward Democratic
Party lies one hoax after another
conspiracy theory after conspiracy
theory take a look at his famed moral
outrage here it's so disappointing to
look at what we're seeing from
right-wing media these days where
there's such an obsession with the deep
state and these revelations about the
Russia probe and the decision about
Michael Flynn they're treating the
Michael Flynn story like it's a bigger
deal than the deaths of 2000 Americans a
day when the president called in to Fox
& Friends the other morning Friday
morning right before the unemployment
rate numbers came out he talked about
the Flynn case for 20 minutes before he
was asked about the pandemic in what
right mind is any scandal any political
scandal any Department of Justice story
more important to ask the president
about than the pandemic that's raging
that Humpty Dumpty's Network obsessed
about in actual hoax for over three
years lying for four straight years but
they want to tell us what's important to
cover him what's not we've been covering
Cova 19 for a long time every single
aspect Humpty it might become a big deal
if you ruin the life of some innocent
general who served this country for 33
years and you set them up and you
surveil them and you unmask them and you
release raw intelligence might want to
ask what Obama knew and when he knew it
are you really that dumb as you see more
maybe just willfully complicit with
democratic state-run propaganda TV of
which you're a big part of me I vote
first see all of the above now because
of what happened to Flynn is just one
part of the deep state's rampant
corruption this is only the tip of the
iceberg but let not your heart be
troubled we believe justice is finally
coming